we can spend a lot of time in
relationships to which we are ostensibly
committed wandering maybe with a fair
amount of anxiety do they love me is
this solid might it all suddenly end but
perhaps less time asking the more
Salient question what can I do to help
this valued relationship endure we can
fall into an era of seeing love as a
passive mysterious gift that we are in
no position to generate direct or
guarantee
rather than conceiving of it as an
emotion that for the most part flows
fairly logically steadily and naturally
on from things that we are in a position
either to do or not to do and to come to
the central thesis love tends to be a
consequence of a partner feeling cared
for and heard in the way that they have
almost certainly frequently signaled to
us that they need to feel in order to be
inwardly assured that they are in safe
and tender hands to Hazard a
generalization most people tend to
Signal their emotional requirements
pretty directly if we are in the mood to
listen in other words there is much we
can choose to do or not to do right now
today in order to weaken or strengthen
our loves
we are for the most part active agents
not passive victimized Spectators the
others love should under normal
circumstances be thought of as a
predictable reward rather than a random
benediction
there are surely cases where people are
Keen to maintain a relationship but are
then left for no reason that they could
ever have guessed at or influenced
normally by people deeply and secretly
ambivalent around the Terrors of
commitment
but in the end there are probably not so
many of those around
to maintain love we need more than
anything to follow a few simple sounding
rules that can nevertheless be very hard
for what we should acknowledge to be
complicated psychological reasons on our
side to act upon
firstly the partner must feel heard
secondly they must feel that we are on
their side
thirdly they must feel appreciated
according to their own distinctive love
language this might mean that we need to
leave the kitchen a certain way or that
we have to take their views of social
life or intimacy into account
fourthly the partner must know that we
are making an effort in their name
fifthly they must feel wanted
emotionally and physically
sixthly insofar as we are difficult to
be around and we all are we must explain
why we need to give our partner an
accurate map to our areas of immaturity
we need to tell them calmly and with
Grace how we are a little mad and with
reference to our pasts why we must never
insist proudly or defensively on our
normality I'm so sorry and I'm listening
should be our two most habitual phrases
lastly seventhly we must strive to
remain calm around our partners most
trying sides we mustn't humiliate them
about their flaws we must become
excellent teachers and diplomats of
difficult messages
if we do all this and a relationship
ends without us wishing to we are
entitled to feelings of acute bitterness
and grief the fault has really not been
with us we have had The Misfortune to
love someone who was not ready to
receive our gift but if the relationship
ends and we have somehow been distracted
or busy we should start to wonder
whether or perhaps why we have wound up
with an ending we told ourselves we
didn't want
we may need to reflect under the full
glare of the truth of singledum that we
might be a lot more ambivalent
conflicted or lackadaisical about
sustaining love than we have imagined